thank you to babel for sponsoring this
video
who were the druids
most of our representations of druids
nowadays are in fantasy books and games
world of warcraft dungeons and dragons
and others present druids as magical
nature wizards
well that's all very fun i think we all
know intuitively that that's not an
accurate representation of historical
druids
when most people think of historical
druids if they think of them at all have
one of two images in their head
one like this a wise man with a white
beard and white robe worshiping and
being in harmony with nature doing some
ancient ceremony at stonehenge or a much
darker image one of dangerous human
sacrifice of heathenus barbarism and
blood and gore
well which of these is correct
[Music]
before we continue here's a quick word
from our sponsor and that sponsor is
babel
summer is upon us and what says summer
more than going on vacation maybe you're
planning a trip to france or indonesia
or south america well wouldn't it be
helpful to know the language of the
country you're going to of course it
would and that's where babel comes in
babel is the premier language learning
app on the market it teaches real world
practical conversations in easy to
digest 10 minute lessons
i'm using it right now to brush up on
the french i learned in college
bonjour
pepe genelez
[Music]
how was my accent need some work yeah
well that's no problem because babel
uses speech recognition software to help
improve your pronunciation and accent i
know my viewers are always looking to
learn new things so whether you're
planning your dream vacation trying to
connect with non-english speakers in
your community or just trying to improve
yourself why not give babel a try
click the link in the description to get
65 percent off
thank you again to babel and now back to
the video
so first off we need some historical
context
[Music]
this region here is the land of the
celts pre-roman invasion
the celts were an ethno-linguistic group
who during the classical period lived
mostly in gaul modern-day france and the
british isles celtic people still exist
today of course residing mostly in wales
scotland and ireland the druids were the
religious leaders of these celtic
peoples
now the celts were in the heyday of
druidism a seemingly illiterate people
at the very least we have no writings
about druids by druids or their
followers this raises an obvious problem
all of the historical accounts of druids
come from outside sources mostly from
greeks and romans
and later medieval irish christians
now this doesn't mean that all the
information given to us by these
non-druids should be overlooked
if we did that we'd have virtually no
information at all and plenty of these
ancient writings can be trusted at least
as much as any other ancient writing
also we now have plenty of
archaeological evidence that sheds light
on the lives of these celts and
presumably the druids as well so modern
scholars are able to match the
information given in the greco-roman
accounts and scrutinize them against the
archaeological evidence
so now that's out of the way who were
the druids
the druids were a social class of
educated people both men and women who
held a very respected place in pre-roman
celtic society they had a number of
roles and responsibilities
first and foremost they were the
religious leaders of the celts druids
understood the spiritual beliefs and
religious practices of the celts and
were the only ones believed to have the
power to communicate with the gods they
also acted as judges settling legal
matters within the tribes and as
advisers to different celtic lords
druids were said to be well-versed in
law ethics medicine and philosophy
their powers were so far-reaching that a
celtic lord would not go to war unless
permitted by the local druid and there
are multiple accounts of druids putting
a stop to battles they thought were
morally wrong
the druids were one of three non-noble
groups honored in celtic society
the other two were the vates whose job
was to perform religious sacrifices as
well as to give prophecy
and the bards who were poets musicians
and satirists
in this video we'll be focusing on the
druids that being said the roles of the
vates druids and bards often overlapped
and in some sources there seemed to have
been no distinction between them at all
with the druids performing all three
functions whether this was because the
writers of those sources like julius
caesar yes that julius caesar were
ignorant of the complexities of celtic
religious life or because in some places
and times the roles were just simpler is
not known
to understand the druids role in society
we have to understand a bit about celtic
paganism
[Music]
unfortunately like the druids themselves
the information we have about celtic
religion is incomplete we know the celts
were polytheists believing in a pantheon
of many gods some of these gods were
local
being gods of specific places like
mountains or rivers
and some gods were more general being
gods of fertility or agriculture for
instance
also there seems to have been different
pantheons of gods in different places
so the gods worshiped in gaul were often
not the gods worshiped in say ireland
these gods were linked heavily with the
natural world in most pagan religions
the gods were thought to be above us
both in a spiritual but also in a
physical sense
the gods of greece lived on mount
olympus for instance
the gods of the celts whoever were
thought to be in nature and underground
living in an underworld of sorts
now that doesn't mean the heavens were
unimportant
greek writers like hakatius of abdera
wrote about how the druids were
knowledgeable in astronomy and that some
celtic people seemed to worship the moon
so the topic of astronomy takes us to
one of the most common misconceptions
about druids
that they
built stonehenge stonehenge one of the
most famous british landmarks is well
known for lining up with several
astronomical events like the summer and
winter solstices
but modern research has revealed that
stonehenge was built in around 2400 bc
which is two millennia before the druids
came on the scene it is certainly
plausible that the druids may have used
stonehenge as a sacred site but they
certainly didn't build it
[Music]
the most important religious practice of
the celts was making offerings to the
gods
this was done by burying valuables in
the ground in large underground stores
or by throwing valuables in sacred
rivers
archaeologists have found many stores of
this sort throughout the celtic lands
and it seems that certain places bogs
and rivers mostly were seen as sacred
animals were also sacrificed
these sacrifices were apparently not
done by the druids but by the vates in
his observations though deodoris
sticulus a greek historian wrote that a
druid was always present at any sort of
sacrifice
even if they didn't do the sacrificing
the animals were also used for
divination the vate after killing the
animal would observe its entrails and
come up with a prophecy based on them
now that leads to the controversial
subject of human sacrifice
many druid enthusiasts as well as some
scholars have argued that the druids did
not in fact practice human sacrifice and
any reference to such things in greek
and roman sources were put there as
anti-druid propaganda there is some
truth in this as many of the roman
sources on druids were written as rome
was conquering gaul and painting the
local celts as savages was a good way of
drumming up support for the war all that
said there is quite a lot of evidence
both written and archaeological that the
celts did indeed perform human
sacrifices
but the celts didn't think of death in
the same way we do now
according to caesar the celts believed
in an immortal soul and in reincarnation
so sacrificing someone for the good of
the tribe when that person's soul was
eternal was well perhaps more acceptable
to them the romans though thought this
practice was barbarous and shocking and
when they conquered gaul they outlawed
the practice
remember however how fond the roman
public was of watching gladiators murder
each other and slaves be killed by lions
in the coliseum
other than sacrifices we have only one
account of a specific druidic ceremony
known as the ritual of oak and mistletoe
it involved a druid cutting a sprig of
mistletoe off an oak tree after two
white bowls had been sacrificed
the druid would then make an elixir from
the mistletoe that was supposed to cure
any ailment this ritual is found in
pliny the elder's natural history so we
don't know precisely how accurate the
account is
still it has become an important image
of druidism in the modern world
the end of druidism came relatively
quickly first with the roman invasion of
gaul in later britain where the
suppression of druidic beliefs started
under emperor augustus in 27 a.d
the germanic migration into france and
england started in the 5th century also
supplanted many celtic beliefs
the last stronghold of the druids was
ireland but the druids and their pagan
beliefs didn't survive once christianity
got to the island
interestingly though the vates who were
called fili in ireland continued into
the 1700s as poets and storytellers
they were the keepers of irish folklore
and were held in high esteem as
satirists their influence slowly died
out starting with the anglo-norman
invasion of ireland in the late 12th
century and ending in the
renaissance
i hope you enjoyed the video thanks
again to babel for supporting the
channel click the link in the
description to get 65 off
also if you're interested in supporting
the channel financially please consider
checking out my patreon it only just
launched and i'll be making an official
announcement in the coming weeks but if
you want to be one of my first patrons
click the link below thanks
bye
[Music]
you